después de dos días terminó la Cumbre de
los líderes hoy con uno de los discursos
más esperados el de Pakistán su Primer
Ministro muhammad sharif propuso que se
cree un índice global de riesgos
climáticos para que se priorice la
financiación a los países que corren más
riesgos como el suyo que enfrentó las
peores inundaciones de la época reciente
otra de las evidencias de esta
injusticia climática se vive en las
islas Cook el Primer Ministro Mark Brown
aseguró que el 99% de su territorio está
a nivel del mar por lo que casi todo
podría inundarse si los océanos crecen
por eso le hizo un llamado al grupo del
g20 que produce el 80% de las
contaminaciones a que contribuya más y
parte de este grupo es la Unión Europea
quien también se pronunció hoy Charles
el presidente del Consejo europeo y
Úrsula bunder Legends la presidenta de
la comisión europea hablaron en el mismo
sentido por un lado reiterar que ha
utilizado la energía como un arma y por
otro decir que el bloque de los 27 ha
sido un campeón climático ya que aportó
21.000 millones de euros para la
financiación climática en 2021 Y aunque
Úrsula Wonderland utilizó un discurso
más fuerte al hacer un llamado a los
países del Norte global a que cooperen
al final nunca mencionó los daños y las
pérdidas recordemos que la Unión Europea
se opuso en Glasgow a la creación de un
fondo para este hecho Y por último la
ONU propuso una agenda para la
adaptación con más de 30 planes que
Espera que se cumplan antes del 2030